if I'm on birth control and I go to my
doctor and I say I'm depressed they do
not even ask you most of the time or or
mention that it might be the birth
control they just pop you on an SSRI or
they pop you on something else and now
you're on a pharmaceutical cocktail and
it gets even worse well I look at a
doctor a lot like a mechanic basically
where they don't actually want to fix a
problem they just want to cut off the
check engine light so you can't see what
the problem is and that's basically why
they just medicate you instead of
actually trying to fix the problem fix
the engine you know actually do the hard
work I just want to give you this you
know Placebo curl yeah but are you
talking about bad doctors yeah but most
doctors are because they'll just give
you an SSRI he's walking and say oh I'm
depressed you know they don't even ask
you 10 questions about wired well maybe
you're going to bed doctors yeah but
this is like no no this is the problem
with doctors are Tim is it you know this
they go to college they come out with
huge debts any doctor that spoke out
against this pandemic protocol you know
got fired so they're they are emboldened
to listen to whatever they're sure
there's this there's no there's no house
in D